tu as lu la team menthe à l'eau en ce
jour des astuces je vais vous donner 5
tips pour être à l'aise à l'oral
par ailleurs si vous êtes abonnés à la
chaîne en fin de vidéo j'aurai deux
annonces à vous faire pour les as beau
être à l'aise à l'oral ça peut être être
à l'aise à l'oral devant une personne à
qui on doit défendre un discours un
propos quelque chose qu'on a à vendre
comme un examen par exemple ça peut être
aussi une prise de parole devant toute
une classe où devant tous ses collègues
ou encore pire dans une grosse
conférence devant des centaines et des
centaines de personnes mais ça peut
aussi être en one-to-one pour commencer
il faut savoir que ce n'est pas inné
d'être à l'aise à l'oral c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on a en soi la
naissance ou qu'on n'a pas c'est une
galère pour tout le monde y a personne
qui est née avec la capacité d'être plus
à l'aise qu'un autre alors 1 5 astuces
rapide parce que là c'est pas un master
class
astuce numéro une vous devez garder à
l'esprit que la forme est aussi
importante que le fond un peu comme en
restaurant ça doit être beau dans
l'assiette et ça doit être bon dans la
bouche
ils échouent souvent vrai ce parallèle
je sais pas pourquoi je choisis ça vous
devez donc soigner le ton les intentions
vous devez bien moduler votre voix
quelqu'un qui nous dirait quelque chose
de très très pertinent mais qui
parlerait toujours comme ça tout le long
tout le temps sans jamais de nuances on
décrocherait immédiatement et bien ça
c'est pareil que vous parliez à une
personne pour un examen que vous parliez
à 500 personnes ou à 1000 personnes pour
une conférence c'est une espèce de mini
représentation vous devez mettre de la
vie là-dedans un petit peu comme quand
vous parlez à vos amis à vos potes ou à
votre famille quand vous raconter
quelque chose vous mettez du relief vous
vivez ce que vous racontez ça doit être
pareil vous devez travailler dans ce
sens là deuxième astuces soyez concis
courtois et pertinents
bafa dans une autre vie c'est aussi on
avait un truc on parlait du ccp clair
concis précis c'est la règle à adopter
quand vous faites un oral même si vous
improviser un travail à l'oral avec
quelqu'un garder cette règle là en tête
avec le plus clair possible le plus
court possible ne pas partir à droite à
gauche tout le temps et précis
évidemment faut que ça touche le but 3e
astuces regarder dans les yeux votre
interlocuteur pas fixement non plus
comme un psycho mais ne fuyez pas son
regard au contraire aller le chercher
vous devez le solliciter vous devez
créer un lien avec cette personne là
vous devez 4t littéralement son
attention et si c'est une grande salle
vous devez aller chercher les regards un
petit peu partout de la même manière
faut reproduire ce naturel dans une
conversation qu'on avait quelqu'un on le
fait naturellement on le perd 1
oral donc il faut penser à retrouver sa
les yeux tout est dans le 4ème astuces
par les plus forts ont jugé assez mal
notre puissance vocale puisque on
s'entend à la fois par l'extérieur et
aussi par l'intérieur en résonance on
pense donc qu'on parle toujours assez
fort et c'est faux pensez-vous à donner
plus de puissance que ce que vous
pensiez donné naturellement et le fait
de forcer un petit peu le volume ça va
vous donner plus naturellement des
intentions des reliefs des émotions des
pics ça va donner de la matière à ce que
vous allez raconter cinquième et
dernière astuce souriez soyez-en joué de
l'intérieur ça doit venir de l'intérieur
c'est pas avoir un sourire crispé comme
ça c'est vraiment se sentir heureux
sentir bien faites vous un petit
discours intérieur avance il faut on
doit ressentir toute votre énergie
positive aller chercher de ce qu'est une
meilleure en vous et laissez le
ressortir sur votre visage rayonnant et
c'est même plus que sourire c'est ça
c'est rayonner j'ai volontairement pas
parler du trac si vous voulez que je
fasse une vidéo sur le trac vous me le
dites dans les commentaires merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo n'oubliez
pas après la outreau après le petit
visuel de fin de vidéo j'ai un message
pour les abonnés et si vous n'êtes pas
abonné vous pouvez tout de suite le
devenir en cliquant sur le petit logo et
comme on dit chez moi si ça vous a plu
n'oubliez pas pouce en l'air rendez vous
comme tous les jours de l'année demain à
17h ciao
voilà le visuel est terminée les deux
petites choses que j'avais à vous dire
sont simples la première c'est qu'hier
on a fait la première vidéo un petit peu
parce qu harry de ce que je lis dans les
commentaires depuis hier ça vous a plu
donc genre frais je sais pas encore à
quelle fréquence je sais pas si je vais
m'imposer comme ça un jour précis de
semaine mais soyez à l'affût je le
mettrais toujours sur les réseaux on le
fera comme ça pareil par tirage au sort
je pense que c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux
moi ça m'a vraiment éclatés de faire ça
si vous aussi bas vas-y on checke et la
deuxième chose c'est que vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué ou pas mais plus ça
va plus la chaîne elle me prend de temps
aussi bien dans l'écriture parce que on
commence à atteindre les 150 vidéos dans
son évolution aussi en tout cas j'espère
je me fais également énormément de
formation et d'une manière générale je
prend plus de temps qu'à voir par
rapport à tout ça il était important que
je trouve une solution pour faire une
espèce de compensation financière parce
que sinon je vais m'en sortir j'ai pensé
dans un premier temps au fameux tipis et
je trouve que ça correspond pas du tout
à ce que je fais je pourrais pas faire
énormément de choses en plus même si
j'avais plein de types heures j'ai donc
choisi la solution la plus simple c'est
d'ouvrir toutes les vidéos aux
publicités y en a qui l'étaient déjà
mais je n'avais pas coché toutes les
options donc voilà j'ai tout fait
j'espère que ça vous dérangera pas
j'espère que vous comprendrez pourquoi
j'ai fait ça ça va me rapporter des
millions mais j'espère que ça me
permettra de prendre encore plus de
temps sur les vidéos et d'investir un
petit peu dessus voilà c'est tout je
trouvais juste ça important de pouvoir
vous l'annoncer à vous qui êtes abonnés
soit depuis le départ soit depuis
récemment mais qui fait partie de la
team mentalité tout ce que j'avais à
dire
alors à demain à 17 heures ciao